Okay, so now I've got these two
equations, I can combine them.
The first one is obvious.
This is the original
brightness constancy equation.
The second one after
I substitute in the,
the Taylor series expansion, there's
a little slight of hand going on.
What I'm doing is,
I'm substituting for this value.
Remember it says that I can get
the location at x plus u, y plus v,
all right?
I can do the Taylor expansion, so
here's the original x, y at t plus 1.
And then there is this derivative part
okay, I of x times u, I sub y times v.
And I of x is the derivative
in the x direction
I of v is the derivative
in the y direction.
Now, students will usually ask me,
wait a minute,
is that a time t or a t plus 1?
>> Is that a time t or a t plus 1?
>> The short answer?
Doesn't matter.
The idea is we're going to assume that
things are changing so slowly and so
gently that the derivative
at a particular point
is going to be the same whether
I look at t or t plus 1.
It's a little bit shall we say, dicey?
But actually, in the limit, it's true.
And we, we only care in
some sense about the limit.
So, taking those two equations,
I've now rearranged things.
I just moved this part over to here.
And then in the next line,
what I did was, this is I sub t.
I sub t is this difference there,
between I of x, y,
t plus 1, minus I of x, y, t.
Well, what is I sub t?
Well, if I of x is the derivative
of I in the x direction,
and I sub y is the derivative
of I in the y direction,
I sub t is the derivative
of I in the time direction.
It's what's called
the temporal derivative.
And remember, our imagery is
now a function of x, y and t.
So, I can take a derivative in x,
in y, or in t.
Another way to think about is, if I just
look at some point x, y and I see how
much the, the image changes from t to t
plus 1, that's my temporal derivative.
And then, finally, on this last one,
you'll see that this here
is just Ix times u plus Iy times v.
That's just the gradient, Ix,
Iy, dotted with however the,
the, the point is moving, that's u, v.
So, we write that like this,
that 0 is approximately It
plus the gradient of the image,
dotted with this vector u, v.
U,v is the direction of motion.
Got it?
Cool, all right, keep going, now,
this is approximation in
the limit as u and v approach 0.
Now you might,
ask how can u and v approach 0?
Well, the idea is that that in the
limit, of course, if t was very small,
the amount of motion you'd
get would be very small,
you would just have the direction.
So we're going to assume
that they're very small and
we're just going to take this
equation directly as is.
That, 0 is equal to It,
plus this, this gradient.
And that, written out either above as
a gradient or here in algebraic form,
that's the brightness
constancy constraint equation.
Say that five times fast.
Brightness constancy
constraint equation.
All right.
Ixu plus Iyv plus It equals 0